buenos dias raúl se trata uno de los
mayores paquetes de sanciones que se han
propuesto hasta la fecha la presenta de
la comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
ha anunciado que en su propuesta en este
sexto paquete de sanciones ampara un
embargo gradual a las importaciones de
petróleo tal y como de hecho se aprobó
también con el carbón en el anterior
paquete de sanciones en los próximos
seis meses se irá reduciendo poco a poco
las importaciones de petróleo de rusia
para que haya una prohibición total ya
para finales de año
von der leyen ha asegurado que aunque no
será fácil hay que hacerse hay que
recordar que la unión europea pago a
rusia más de 70 mil millones de euros
por su petróleo en el año pasado por lo
tanto no sé no será nada fácil ni para
rusia ni tampoco para las economías
europeas de hecho países como eslovaquia
y también hungría fuertemente
dependientes de la energía de rusia hay
que tener en cuenta que son dos países
que no tienen salida al mar al mar
pueden sufrir fuertemente las
consecuencias por ello tendrán
excepciones la comisión europea propone
que estos dos países no tengan que tener
esta prohibición total hasta el año que
viene y así se podría evitar que
bloqueen estas sanciones cuando los
países lo aprueben así las discusiones
pueden ser complicadas también en la
propuesta se ampliará que haya más
bancos apartados del sistema swift entre
ellos en la mayor entidad de rusia el
sberbank von der leyen también propone
sanciones a militares y altos mandos que
hayan participado las debuta así como en
la sede en el asedio de la ciudad de
mariupol además también se prohíbe que
tres canales de televisión rusos puedan
seguir retransmitiendo dentro de solo
europeo porque según von der leyen
también están expandiendo mentiras sobre
la guerra en ucrania las nuevas medidas
se esperan que se puedan hoy presentar a
las capitales europeas y pueden
aprobarse en los próximos días aunque
comentábamos las discusiones no serán
fáciles